now back in May we showed you this US
magazine 25 things you don't know about
y'all read these you know I I this is I
did one of these ones all people in show
business have been subject to this you
do 25 things you don't know about me and
we showed you that Hillary Oh some of
the things are fascinating like she said
Bill Clinton proposed to me twice before
I said yes
and that wasn't even about marriage no
she said number 13 I am always and will
be a Beatles fan I also really love
Adele because of course I'm not
pandering to Millennials at all what I
said so then we did the Ted Cruz edition
we said they should do Ted Cruz next and
he had he had ones like mirrors don't
show my reflection
my nickname at Princeton was
and then we did the Bernie Sanders
edition where he said things like shaker
very used to wear a t-shirt with me on
it
and I combed my hair with a balloon so
so we were waiting until the eve of the
Republican convention to finally do 25
things you don't know about me Donald
Trump all right when I masturbate my
tiny hands make my penis look bigger
I don't drink alcohol I cause others to
drink alcohol not only do I read the
Bible the Book of Revelations mentions
me by name Mara Largo is Spanish for
house of douche I saved the Box Melania
arrived in so I can return her when she
turns away I never actually believed
Obama was born in Kenya because I
thought the name of the country was
Kanye sometimes late at night I worry
that my obsessive self aggrandizement
and self-promotion are symptoms of inner
weakness and a transparent childish
impulse that everyone can see I worry
they're laughing and how obvious it is
that I'm an abandoned frightened child
swirling in a black emptiness but then I
tweak about my poll numbers and I
feel better
I cry at movies because they're
integrated the original name for Trump
Tower was my big shiny penis building I
like things made of gold more than every
Persian combined I can peel a banana
with my feet
when I get bored around the office I
make Chris Christie dance around in a
diaper